you think the next step what do you want
to do don't do anything until you know
you know the way people say money Burns
a holy pocket and they really mean you
just want to buy some fresh gear
actually a lot of times it's in this
scenario where you're like what do I
invest in I want to do it proper Don't
Force It but keep looking for [__] that
excites you to get into do you like
selling things yeah then find things to
sell if someone's lucky enough to like
selling things then they just keep
having to find things that they like to
sell sneakers wasn't a thing that people
sold when I was a kid now it's [__]
real sports cards nfts clothes it could
be something left field but find
something you want to sell